[Musique]
je suis passé des idéaux aux vidéos de
nombreuses idées flou à laver de faux tu
t'étais son délire mais cela peut-être
par chaque sorte un même regard des
staffs des bas mais non mais non faut
faire de grandes études c'est chiant
c'est chiant pas besoin regarde et une
règle ya plus d'enfants sans mes vidéos
que sans canal j j'ai ainsi qu'il m'a
donc pour les paroles tu demandes à
nagui cité images pousse les gens à
mettre au fond du katri influence serge
auscultant sur les derniers votes sa
copie car j'ai plus je me rends pour la
jeune âge chez pas changer une ampoule
irresponsable beaucoup de stress chaque
projet mon front sans doute tu souris
réseau mais mon chien fait plus que toi
tu me jury mais quand le cancer tela de
droite reconnaît pas mais fidh et omct
et en la matière pour séduire une fiche
fait une dédicace pour son petit frère
on avait dit
on sait pas qu'en fait elle est destinée
à dire des paroles en l'air
aussitôt qu'on s'y met pas de consignes
pas de coups
on a l'esprit
on fait pas qu'en faire
décrivez
des paroles en l'air tap est requise
sitôt confirmée
de conflit
la vue sur la vallée la ville assure la
mère vu qu'on ait fait l'élève finale
celle là même en vélo seuils de selena
ont juste fallait nay suis fan comme
senna senna sont des scènes et des
scénars qu'est ce qu'on essaye là haut
on fait du rap on s'éloigne dans le flot
d'infos rac aurait fini la fête comme un
connard serein je trouve ça facile en
fait je suis pas si l'enfer je suis
lancinant sers toi je suis quasiment
certain plaire à ceux qui captent qu'on
fait ce qui nous plaît parce que c'est
qu'il est simple j'ai tendance à
indiquer sans même appliquée je vais pas
paniquer nappes blanches et comme j'ai
pas confiance je prends conscience que
j'en sais rien je vais me renseigner sur
ça mais je crois seulement qu'on s'en
sort bien on censure rien je me sens
soudain qu on s'assume 1 et si tu
m'insultes j'suis pas que celui qui s'en
souvient un peu prête au jeu du commun
des mortels aucun démenti demande au
ciel mon potentiel je suis des mensuels
loin de penser beaucoup d'anciens pas de
recette que dure celle des naissances
mais tu référencé comme gerets et je
peux être maire c'est vrai csb j'ose
espérer faire un cd pour excès
on sait pas quand on est déprimé
aussitôt qu'on s'y met pas de consigne
pas de consignes
et puis
on fait pas qu'en fait on serait des
prix
m
c'est au conflit mais là
nous à percer mais la paire est allé
plus vite ou bungie pas les pèlerines le
trophée bataille n'est pas les bosseurs
des grands pas se faire je mène ma
douceur d'ailleurs un peu mais quand je
faisais là soit tu te tais toi tu toi
pas tous qui singe ta bouche on comprend
ce foutu plus drôle quand tu choques à
la dôle et maxou temmar en parlant tuer
mais c'est bizarre tout ce sur quoi tu
fais pas fille pourquoi tu décroches
mais on sait pas que tu fais de ta vie
de tes journées on sait que c'est pour
déconner et musique tatouage vt sur et
du chant qui demeure discret le 15 a eu
sa me fait que commencer
[Musique]
ce que fait le si bien copié collé pour
ce week-end
car en demeure à 16 heures perdues dans
un train pascal erre entre nîmes et
paris je préfère compter des d'outré la
tournée continue
j'exagère ma vie bien que cher à pardies
vous avoir dans mon coeur me mènera au
paradis un max tu as vraiment [ __ ]
ambiance à part que tu trouves dans tout
[ __ ] on arrive on sait pas quand
[Musique]
et hop on s'y met pas de conflit n'y pas
d'accord
d
on sait pas grand enfant
destiné
paroles en l'air
tout est là
aussitôt qu'on s'y met
de consignes
pas de vanter
y'a pas
nous à percer mais l'appétit
[Musique]
y'a pas sur nous la paix mais la paix
qui est à faire